So now that we know that
when we have a cache miss,
we fetch an entire block
worth of stuff from memory,
let's talk about where can
these blocks begin in memory.
One option is a block
can begin anywhere.
So let's say we have 64 byte blocks.
That means that a block, for
example, might go from
address 0 through 63 bytes.
Or it can be from 1 through 64.
Or it can go from 2 to 65, and so on.
So pretty much if the starting
address of the block can be anywhere,
then these are the possible blocks
that we might fetch in our cache.
This complicates things a lot.
First, our cache is a table.
We want to index into
the table using some bits
of the address that we are accessing.
But let's say that what we
are accessing is the address 27.
The problem is the block
can actually be found
wherever the beginning
address of the block maps.
So block 0 to 63 might
map here in the cache.
Block 1 through 64 might map somewhere
else in the cache and so on.
So basically,
there are many possible places where
the address 27 might be,
simply because each of these blocks
might map somewhere else depending
on what its beginning address is.
Second, there is another complication,
which is these blocks overlap.
So the block 0 through 63 contains
stuff that overlaps with most
of what 1 through 64 contains.
So this, other than this,
is the same stuff.
Now, the problem is when we are reading,
it's easy.
We just need to read one
of these copies for 27.
But when we are writing, we need to
determine which of the copies exist and
write to all of them so that reading
any of them will still be okay.
So pretty much,
we don't want this to happen.
We don't want to have multiple places
where the same byte address might be.
So in order to both reduce the
complexity of accessing the cache, and
eliminate the problem of this
repetition of stuff in the cache,
we will only have caches where the
blocks start at block aligned addresses.
So for a 64-bit block,
we will have a block that
contains data from 0 to 63 bytes.
The next block begins at byte 64 and
goes to 127 and so on.
So pretty much any byte address can
be found in only one of the possible
blocks.
That also allows us to simply use
some bits of the address that
tell us which of these blocks
are we talking about, and
index into the cache, and find it there.
So there is only one place in the cache
where each of these will fit, and so on.
So for all reasonable caches, we will
really only consider aligned blocks.
Meaning, you cannot fetch any 64 bytes,
or 32 bytes, or
whatever block size is from
memory into the cache.
We need to fetch the 64 byte block that
contains the data and is block-aligned.